[Musique]
la serons nous de pareilles traces sur
le sol lunaire
en attendant de le savoir ce promeneur
découvrait hier un pari au relief tout
adoucie par la neige des parcs devenu
mystérieux lachaise où le banc le plus
banal recouvert d'un éphémère coussin de
velours blanc neige artistes ménages
traîtresse aussi dont il fallait déblayé
une couche de 10 cm qui recouvrait en
fin de matinée la plupart des rues de la
ville afin qu'elle n'oblige pas les
parisiens à effectuer des figures
imposées de patinage
beaucoup de citadins rester chez eux
mais çà et là des envolées d'enfants
célébrer l'événement joyeusement
soulageront des pigeons toute chose
enfin était enrichie de ce léger fait ce
temps qui rendait hommage à l'infinie
variété des formes que l'on n'a pas
toujours le temps d'apprécier
[Musique]